c'est l'heure de l'épisode 5 la dernière
fois on a fini sur la chute tragique de
tricot et de l'enfant ça nous a mis un
peu en pls on va pas se mentir mais
c'est sûr ils sont vivants j'espère
c'est parti oui lui les livres métriques
au mikes et tricot surtout qu'on va voir
t'affole pas tu vas faire péter la
brindille au jeu peu le contrôle et la
voix le but de ces cas se cacher
partenaires ouais tu combats les tricots
bas il va bien quand je fais pour
descendre tricot et de moi je suis
bloqué c'est bon il m'a vu il va pouvoir
m'aider ou penser tu mets tricot mais
c'est pas sûr le plier à demain mon
grand tu as faudrait que tu sautes dans
l'évolution et que tu m'as trappe
oh oui ça y est tu vas mêlée tu viens
m'aider
tu me récupère au [ __ ] merde
à ta tante et bien je mon grand bien
j'ai bien joué un jeu on va trouver une
solution
kramer d' eau il attendait quelque chose
oh oui et s'est accroché aux branches
trick à la queue se péter la queue à
lula que allez on n'est pas loin
pour cela un peu oui c'est bon merci
tricot il a fait balancer ça qu il est
trop mal a et b mon grand tu étais tu
t'étais lieu sûr juste et là ok purée on
a fait une belle chute mon gars mais
tous les deux tellement c'est à croire
qu'on soit encore en vie
vois-tu bien on s'était pris des balles
chute avec l'enfant aussi alors mais
revoilà sur ton dos qu'est-ce qu'on fait
une fois qu'on est là on va redescendre
ouais ouais ouais très bien mon grand
président et son bail à rien alors
comment à ya les papillons il ya là vous
pas loin pour toi alors à temps voyons
voir ce qu'il a à faire c'est trouver
l'amour alors théâtre
tout y passe que tout où il a bu ou du
tout d'un coup tout cas maintenant
mais non mon gars on est retourné mais
tellement loin c'était dans l'épisode où
ont commencé à sauter sur le dos de
tricot je crois olalala [ __ ] longueur
ouais j'sais pas comment tu peux pas
venir là tu va pousser la grinta
messieurs tout qui leur dit autour du
cou dont on me dit certains hôtels ont
donc voté comme acquis sociaux tout du
long
nato jonathan alors tout il a dit
j'adore les vidéos de là tout est train
de repérer tête par la caf alors lancé
ça c'est sûr pour finalement arriver là
ouais faut se démerder pour que le
tonneau arrive là et qu'on refasse le
tour comme ça le jeter là pour récupérer
la et l'envoyer au caire je pensais ça
ok au pelage leur pend direct voilà ça
me permet de passer ensuite soit faut
l'envoyer là soit fall envoyé là-bas
directement mais j'y crois pas trop trop
j'aurais plus d'îles ad'abord way maïs
je leur prends ok c'est morse enigmo
autonome me souviens que j'avais agi
comme un connard dans l'a310 pas de
chance hop je leur prends les bons et là
je peux l'envoyer là bas directement je
pense aller fort parce que put tricot a
parfois ses poteries correspond aux
questions et maintenant on peut
directement lui amener t'attrape dirait
dans la gueule ait des blessés un oeil
pour y faire un oeil chope
ça peut pas voulu ailleurs le vieil s'y
tient j'ai pas trop on peut aller là
tecau serait mêlé ou pas vas-y vas-y
fais ton sens je suis sur toi d'utoeya
les pièces redescend très bien que sans
toi je suis père du bébé voilà désolé je
te fais tu le caches ton énergie pour
rien mon gars mais franchement tu partes
tellement vite en même temps tu
m'envoies 7g dans la gueule quoi quand
tu sors c'est bon oh [ __ ] j'ai bien
failli pas de vieira non plus alors donc
là c'est là où on était au début tu vars
hautes et c'est ça moi je reste accroché
alors je suis prêt à accrocher
yes ensuite quand et là on fait quoi
mais je te laisse te l'algérie c'est ton
c'est ton délire alcoa
tu as trouvé l'asie il ya en eu
effectivement ok on est bon ou non voilà
dehors on a perdu tellement de hauteur
tricot à cause de l'autre bête tu vas
ouais moi je te les gérer la pilote
automatique tricot
ouais au top saute allez vas-y yahoo
aux pionniers et maintenant où les
bâtards à les bâtards ils ont des
children des boucliers en fait la
matière et deux du fond de la forme que
tricot des tests [ __ ] projet semble en
tout cas c'est sûr ok lumière va pouvoir
y aller par ici et comment on fait faut
qu'on les attirent bon pour clore
boucler ce casse
[ __ ] je maintenant qu'on va pouvoir
faire puisque habituellement là il ya
que le faire il ya pas les mecs qui
peuvent lui péter la gueule le vert il
est seul il va puis se défend pas là
c'est sous forme de bouquet donc un mec
qui le tient oui dans le caca on est en
train de passer dessous en fait ouais
les gars ne sont juste d'être coupé
tricot il est là est en train de bas des
ambiances et puis train de boucler les
mongueurs up
ouais c'est en face
trajet mme trop la musique quand il ya
du danger la musique elle est folle est
tellement merdique
je me trouve on va faire le tour enfin
tours on peut rentrer par la cage aux
[ __ ] il était garé juste la mecque
c'est chaud de toute manière va devoir
engager une course poursuite c'est sûr
et peut-être qu'il faut que je les que
je les attire les mains quelque les
boucliers je parle comme ça tricot
pourra venir
ok mais je peut esquiver n'ont pas pu
toucher n'importe quoi est lâche moi ça
dégage ok ouais ok sont nombreux ouais
c'est bien ce que je pense que je les
attire
owens pour faire tomber les mains ok
tricot je demande elle fait son tricot
et les arêtes autsai et des actes
oh mais à des moyens moi je m'en suis au
lit comme sachant sécurité
et je vais le casser pour le calmer à
l'égard d'autres gosses se calme on se
calme
ok tu casses la caméra tu te casses la
caméra c'est bon mouvement pour la paix
alors on va où maintenant et si on à gré
à kubrick le passé regard ils vendent
des barreaux ok bon moi je moi c'est pas
toi
mais bon je vais t'ouvrir bien
évidemment tu vas me rejoindre très très
vite tu t'en doutes à barr yard regardez
à quoi servait le trou s'est
spécialement pour toi on sent le foeil
l'attention 3 devant le fun alethia
manges tu as besoin de force là takkari
la game et toi bien
pendant ce temps là je vais voir les
chemins possibles ben voilà c'est
celui-là allez on y va tricot c'est
parti à gauchy à rien et à droite
aulas attend c'est des mecs c'est des
gardes c'est quoi ce pas des gardes
bon bah tricot en tout cas tu adores
m'amener juste là où toi même tu peux
voir je l'entends pour aller là
hier waouh
elle en a du choix là un [ __ ] juste là
au fait en face au lit mickaël alphonse
yes le dernier donc là à mon avis déjà
j'y vais tout de suite mais ouais il ya
une échelle je pense qu'elle n'est pas
là pour rien voilà attends je vais
t'ouvrir je vais te vois je vais
t'ouvrir
je te retrouve ça
comme ça toi tu passes voilà et moi je
peux passer entre les bornes hop là il
est au yo-yo le conte tricot au [ __ ]
il est descendu en bas il ya une sorte
de potion merde [ __ ]
ok ça va s'il tombe de très haut mais
s'exerce surtout quand ça autant cloudy
with you do not etc ou hinault johnny
tout en tricotant madoff était surtout
aux moules à gâteaux et nous à sauver
100 mille fois tricot vos gains alors
c'est sur un rail je crois qu'on peut
voir le tir et ouais c'est ça on peut le
tirer
on va de ce pas le tirer ok on est bien
là on peut pas le pousser s'il ya un peu
de tout c'est l'autre côté
[Musique]
ça jamais les mères qui tuent repoussant
au bouquet
à regarder il ya deux rails il ya deux
rails doit y avoir un truc à activer
quelque part et là où il ya un truc
auquel je pense que
je suis censé accepter ça m'amènerait
derrière les grilles est ça me
paraîtrait de déclencher ce levier ouais
alors on y retourne ok c'est fait
maintenant faut vite que je monte sur
tricot voilà on a accédé au truc on va
pouvoir aller activer le levier qui là
bas je sais pas encore à quoi il sert
mais peut-être que ça change le
l'aiguillage iata yes bingo plaide go ça
va se casser et bernard parterre pensé
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
en plus sa bouche le trou quoi va me
rejoindre
holy shit je vais devoir voler je vais
devoir nager par l'angola je dois me
servir de ce truc comme un fauteur je
suppose et juste te tuerais d'un nouveau
tricot à je dois me servir de ça pour
atteindre quelque chose mais quoi tu pas
mais délaissée pendant que comme tu fais
à chaque fois voire [ __ ] de miracle à
tout hasard fait pas de tapis donne que
a peut-être qu'il faut le faire sauter
comme ça il va casser le truc regardez
les planches basis hautes castes ska le
bois ouais ouais ouais nickel way a les
pieds cost p
voilà [ __ ] ya là que la à l'évasion
n'est pas iata oh [ __ ] je mette aussi
content de retrouver ta que nice
merci mon pote format du coup on
continue un du coup on attend on venait
de là bas il faut continuer vers la
barrière psychologique
let's go tu vas devoir faire un [ __ ]
de saut bien sûr pas timide mais si tu
vas tu peux faire le saut tu vas aller
là-haut à d'accord ok j'ai compris
basile this way caisse ou encore halo
dessus la whey pièce nickel pourquoi
pour une musique comme ça
mais allez sa cage le saccage le sait
bien ni calme parfait ok il est calme
mais on va pouvoir avancer mon cher
tricolore par on va s qu'il faut qu'on
aille plutôt vers la lumière
oui c'est quoi cet endroit a tancé le
portage peut l'ouvrir
on dirait un wagon de train dans ce film
porte bizarre vert ici c'est le dehors
pas y faire grand chose
[ __ ] il est mal encore faut que je
trouve de la bouffe
merdre about simplement déjà connu alors
comment faire pour ramener ce taux nos
abonnés il faut coller ça au trou et m
et envoyez tonneau dessus par fait face
tout cela jusqu'avant droite
[Musique]
oui les postures à non j'aurais dû
coller la truck
maintenant je suis à fond en fait je
peux faire mieux bon sinon on perd il ya
une autre une autre caisse mais à quoi
elle peut servir à rien et ça a c'est ok
d'accord je compris les deux serbes
on va la coller à l'autre comme ça ira
plus de longueur et le tonneau il
tombera pas l'autre côté ok on a à peu
près bon lancer numéro un mais qui l'eu
cru mais qui l'eût cru
tiens poteau c'est pour toi
et maintenant on va pas s'en aller
il est content qu'on ait prévu comme ça
ce qu'il est heureux en gros clicquot là
tu vas devoir sauter dans le trou qu'est
la voilà qui ramène ton âme et un même
toit
hélas hélas tu va sauter là où tu vois
très bien de quoi je parle tricot voilà
là aussi ça exactement
t'as tout compris allez mon gars nice
alors je vais voir comment faire plutôt
un mec moi tu en fais pas au [ __ ] ça
promet si je meurs pas je sais pas
mourir il faut que j'aille de l'autre
côté où est-ce qu'il faut juste que je
descende sur ce toit là sur l'absence
des juges de l'autre côté je pense qu'il
faut aller là bas
ouais faut traire c'est ça mais tricot
où il pouvait me suivre la merde [ __ ]
mais c'est bel et bien une sorte de
conduit 2 trains vous avez vu ça
ressemble un train [ __ ] j'ai même pas
vu qu'elle trie
hu
oh [ __ ] je sautais tricot
pardon je suis foutu faut soulever sa
visite
oh non c'est horrible si près du but
sans bruit
non
[Musique]
peut-être voix c'est bon c'est qu'on
avait sauté trop tôt tout à l'heure ok
retournera au hockey ni quelle [ __ ]
merci trop mon gars pour la millième
fois kim sur la vie c'est juste
incroyable haut du dos aubin qu'est ce
tu veux ces nouveaux avocats
je veux sauter là bas ouais bah si samba
sur la montagne
ouais enchaîne vite par contre j'ai pas
envie de me faire remarquer il a
décroché au [ __ ] on dirait l'entrée
d'un poste la salade on dirait qu'on va
tomber nez à nez dans une arène face à
l'hôte tricot à sa spécialité les
spéciaux où tu sais que ça arrive à ma
voilà du coup au spawn l'a directement
ça va plus vite très bien [ __ ] tricot
suis assez plate forme usa tu planes
paul deux fois au [ __ ] c'est le nommer
que ces marraine
c'est vraiment une arène pour le coup il
n'y a pas de vitré qui fait patrick
o'connor bomba tricot asie pour y aller
1 à lille vont avoir des bouquets je
vais devoir l'aider je pense ok il faut
que je sais que j'ai cette visite irak
ont débouclé là bas
bartois obata au placebo cassez vous
basez base de tricot pour un capot
bouclier est basse et de leurs proches
casse toi c'est mon avis et face2face
situe le bitume béton qui leur prêtent
les grosses c'est bon on ice mon gars tu
l'as explosé et là encore vivants ils
sont plus résistants ceux qui vouent
claire et le petit dernier
c'est mon gars alors maintenant qu'on
est là qu'est ce qu'on fait mon ami ni
les papillons il doit avoir la bouffe
attends je vais monter de l'autre côté
moi regarde regarde comme j'ai vu juste
c'est pour toi tricot ça c'est fait
alors comment me sortir ici par contre
que tu as fait ta tuque à quoi la jda
fédrigo là haut il ya des trous et lake
que des grilles à wave asie vas-y vas-y
fais ça mon gars c'est bien ouais yes
merci mon gars elle reçoit qu'il a deux
côtés merde heureusement qu'il a ce côté
joueur qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc
je le mette en plein mieux la lumière en
plein milieu de la pub et ça mais ça va
être pour atteindre l'est la grille là
au foot au tricot et regardant aussi sûr
c'est ça on va se faire catapulter voilà
tu vois ça se bascule mon gars tu
comprends bah oui tu comprendrais pas du
tout comtois vazia plus un grand coup de
sucre pas un gros coup de patte
vas-y ouais ouais
trop cool mon gars à trop trop bien ça
c'était très très bien ça a beaucoup plu
ah ben voilà un petit levier tiens j'ai
pas trop quand je porte le libérer mais
on va se démerder tricot ok mais qui
s'ouvre avec deux [ __ ] un levier
d'accord ok j'arrive quand je t'entends
queen est là ça va hop voilà c'est quoi
ça c'est un truc j'ai eu une sorte qui a
bouffé ali donné il va il peut passer en
bas là où patrick aux voiles à la fois
qui saute bien viendra en sortant mon
grand oui mais regarde pas comme ça tu
as très bien compris arrive à venir
voilà et maintenant on va accéder à
l'autre côté en fait part ici et quand
on sera la tête au dessus
n'empêche chose non plus bon il avance
doucement mais sûrement peut-être sur le
toit là bas du cou mais là-bas y avait
une grille fermée tous les moyens
d'ouvrir peut-être sauter à malhao il va
sauter là où tu vas là haut allez allez
allez allez voiture garde déjà c'est que
tu sais que cruelle attention attention
voilà tu vas quand tu as donc on
atterrit dans une petite grotte avec un
fou donnons ce pas peur à tricot les
fonds d'eau mais bon on n'est jamais à
l'abri d'une surprise
et ici en barils oui hayat a perdu du
temps par on peut passer c'est nico
habana o a laissé trouver tu mets bien
tout là haut 3 2 1
on peut faire on peut mieux faire sur la
synchro ok on est au top
merci mon gars alors par où je peux
aller ici tu n'expliques tricot comment
je fais euh ok yolo ya pas 36 solutions
tic au let go ou hp pour gemalto
mais oui je peux plongée mon gars je
bougeais jusqu'où d'un salaire carrément
profonde à anouk et je peux pas aller
plus bas que ça ok alors je pense qu'on
peut passer juste là dessous à mon avis
y on vient d'apprendre à plonger c'est
sûrement parce qu'on doit plonger
pourquoi à pour passer à la suite pour
moi c'est là clairement il sera élevé
l'autre côté tout c'est l'âme on est
obligé d un peu plus bas oui un truc que
j'ai raté bah voilà
allez allez allez allez ça c'est fait on
n'en parle plus à l'est a tenu dès qu'il
a pu tous fait moins le malin
vas-y remonte assez bon pas certain de
paniquer pour lui à tiko est une queen
tutu dessin mais qu'un tu l'as déjà fait
je sais que tu es capable donc tu vas
pas me prendre pour un coin qui est
offert
la porte car à quoi je suis corps et
bien tu sautes je te regarde
mais aller il va y aller kiss you
flahaut
[ __ ] rester mon pote c'est bien mon
grand et petites caresses donc je crois
que c'est au vert la grille donc falloir
qu'on plonge à tricot tu me suis si je
plonge je me suis dit faut aller là bas
pour aller là-bas scheckter pas envie
mais enfin qu'on plonge mon gars tu peut
plonger à toi aussi non let's go ils
passent dans le trou on est au top
[ __ ] doc et populaire plongé lui aussi
ah ouais il va beaucoup plus profond est
beaucoup plus vite quoi tu aimes fait
confiance à fait bien bien joué [ __ ]
on l'a fait mec trop cool
on sait qu'ils possèdent sèche toi bon
vers là-bas je suppose en dessous la
grille encore allez on va faire ça bingo
j'ai plongé et comme promis regarder
comment ça je peux pas atteindre sa peau
de phoque
l'échelle est cassée au les chiites
tout ça pour rien je fais tout ça pour
rien fait genre une grosse bombe
voilà comme ça dans l'eau savent comme
ça peut-être je vais m'envoler comme
avec la cnaf août
ces lots ça me un geyser ok vas le faire
on va le faire
oui ça a marché il a sauté et ça fait
une [ __ ] de vague manga j'ai pu
atteindre le levier est fantastique
et comme avoir voyagé ensemble mon
amoureux allez vas-y sûrement arriver
allez on y va on va dans le trophée sa
vie puisque j'ai pas pu l'éviter non
plus mais bon là je vois que tu donnes
tout ce que tu peux c'est très bien on
n'y va pas je vais crever là
merde quoi je m'embarquais
tricot vite
mais non hormis cet aréna auteur du
chrono et de creuser à la salle inertie
au oui
bad et par voilà sein de ce 5ème ou 6ème
place je sais même plus tellement je
suis bouleversée n'hésitez pas allez ça
vous a plu
comme d'habitude et surtout très vite
pour le prochain plus que deux ou trois
épisodes et c'est la fin du l'esprit eh
bien écoutez j'ai hâte qu'on va se
lâcher sur samba sall au regard des
attraits neuf chaînes vidéo portez vous
bien que tout le monde
[Musique]